the booming steps echoed through the
museum corridors pharaohs Emperors and
Mongolian War leaders all stood stock
still as the terrified security guard
ran between them Roger Pascal swung his
flashlight this way and that the light
glinted on the polished steel of ancient
Weaponry muskets scimitars and cannons
exhibit after exhibit flashed past him
as he ran through the dark Museum there
was no way it was real no possible way
he was having a bad dream that's all it
was a bad dream the shaking ground under
his feet and the marching Rhythm of the
impossibly heavy footsteps behind him
told him that it was real all right it
had just been a normal shift like any
other just a regular Night at the Museum
Roger had been sipping his coffee and
listening to the radio when all of a
sudden he felt his chair start rumbling
beneath him he put his coffee down on
the table and washed as it recoiled as
the footsteps grew louder and closer he
got up to investigate and couldn't
believe what he'd walked in on skidding
around the corner he tumbled into a
medieval suit of armor and scented
crashing across the floor chainmail
helmet gauntlets all of it rattled and
crashed to the marble floor echoing all
through the museum then there was a
sudden deathly silence as the footsteps
stopped Roger didn't breathe then they
started again heading straight towards
him it was all Roger could do to lie on
his back in front of the giant Taxidermy
eagle and point his flashlight at the
door as the Monstrous figure of the
stone Soldier walked around the corner
musket in hand Woodstock Vermont
1995. it was a normal day just like any
other the birds were singing in the
trees and there was a gentle breeze
blowing through nothing at all out of
the ordinary except of course the statue
that opened its eyes Civil War Memorial
had been a staple of Woodstock for well
over 100 Years A plinth sitting in the
middle of a park with a young Soldier on
top of it holding a musket peacefully by
his side the statue had watched over the
town generation after generation except
now its watching had become a little
more active it took several hours for
anyone to notice dog walkers went past
listening to their walkmans a banker sat
on a bench opposite deep in conversation
on a giant brick phone it was only when
a young child running after her football
looked up at the Statue and saw it
looking back at her that things changed
the girl's parents didn't listen to her
of course parents rarely do but word
quickly went around the girls school
most of the time the statue was totally
still no movement in the eyes at all but
on occasion would a group of kids
gathered around it and talked to it
enough the statue seemed to look down at
them as if it was listening but that was
it no grown-ups were particularly
interested in what the children were
saying and even a lot of the children
who saw it went home concluding that
they must have been imagining things so
six months went by without anyone really
paying the statue much attention that
was until it fired its gun in a quiet
rural Town everyone hears a gunshot but
for a long time no one could work out
where it had come from police gathered
around the park searching all around
where the weapon had been heard the only
clue they could find was a small hole in
the wall of a shop across the street a
couple of officers joked that the shot
must have come from the statue itself
everyone laughed it off except for a
couple of the school kids who were
playing nearby less than two weeks later
another shot rang out in the middle of
the night and a group of confused police
officers rushed to the park to
investigate what had happened the only
thing they found was a dead bird lying
on the sidewalk shot to death again the
jokes went around the department that it
must have been the statue who did it
except this time the officers were all
laughing a little less enthusiastically
without much crime going on in Woodstock
Vermont the department decided to take
the shooting quite seriously going so
far as to perform an autopsy on the dead
pigeon but when they cut the animal open
and looked at the wound inside its chest
they were filled with even more
confusion than they were before it
wasn't a conventional bullet lodged into
the bird's rib cage at all it was
perfectly round and made of what
appeared to be Stone but the next shot
that rang out from the Memorial Park was
unmistakable it was a weekend in the
middle of the summer vacation so the
park was full of families all sitting
around having picnics barbecues and
staring up at the sky watching the birds
Circle lazily overhead bang one of the
pigeons exploded in a burst of feathers
and plummeted out of the sky landing on
the sidewalk in front of the whole town
in shock all the townsfolk turned around
to see the stone statue down on one knee
with his musket on his shoulder the
statue looked down at all of them
surprised at the attention then quickly
got back to its feet and resumed its
normal stance reports flooded all the
local papers and news stations the event
was blamed on mass hysteria a kind of
group hallucination where everyone was
somehow sharing the same story but the
number of people coming forward with the
exact same account was irrefutable
evidence that's where the foundation had
to step in in January 1996 containment
procedures began and the statue was
given the designation
scp-011 of course a large contingent of
Agents suddenly appearing in a small
town would raise a lot of Suspicion so
the foundation had to move very
cautiously One agent at a time the
foundation established itself in
Woodstock and began to study the statue
day in and day out by sitting on park
benches even looking through cut out
holes in newspapers and wearing fake
outfits so as not to arouse suspicion
steadily over time the statue appeared
to gain either a heightened Mobility or
just a renewed sense of confidence while
much of the time it did remain standing
immobile it would begin to occasionally
stretch when it thought no one was
looking and glanced this way and that in
apparent annoyance with the birds
circling over its head the shooting
steadily grew more regular Foundation
agents observed several birds being
picked out of the sky by the musket fire
of scp-011 over the following weeks a
clear pattern started to emerge the
statue would only fire at birds that
seemed to be flying above it or getting
too curious about it in fact the more
fecal matter built up on the Statue the
more aggressive it would be both in its
body language and mood seemed to sour
the dirtier it got while there were
initial concerns about the SCP
potentially turning its rifle towards
the local townspeople these worries were
largely dismissed as scp-011 gradually
started to build up a rapport with those
around it before long the caretakers of
the park were having exchanges with the
SCP these exchanges started with the
caretaker speaking directly to the SCP
and at nodding or subtly acknowledging
the things they said but over time the
interactions grew more and more
personable in the year 2000
scp-011 spoke for the first time it had
just fired its rifle picking off a
pigeon from over 200 feet away when a
caretaker mildly exclaimed nah shot the
statue smiled dipped his hat to the
caretaker and said Thank you in a
gravelly voice this marked a significant
change in the foundation's approach to
the containment of scp-011 up until this
point the SCP was considered a broadly
harmless member of the local town
community however its ability to speak
raised concerns as to this scp's
development four years ago it had been
an immobile statue with nothing out of
the ordinary to raise any suspicions
among those around it where would its
cognitive development end now that it
had gained the ability to talk
groundskeepers and agents posing as
groundskeepers struck up conversations
with scp-011 as often as possible at
first these exchanges were brief but
over time the SCP became steadily more
vocal until soon it was engaged in
intellectual debates and sharing its
views on the world with anyone who would
listen was becoming clear that new
containment measures were needed in fact
scp-011 soon lost interest in shooting
birds or rather the SCP was persuaded to
stop shooting birds while the prospect
of having animals defecate on it still
appeared to anger the statue the
foundation was able to explain through
ideological grounds why shooting birds
was a disproportionate response relative
to the minor harm they were doing to it
King to engage in philosophical and
ethical discussions the statue she was
very open to hearing the foundation's
viewpoint on the issue and having
sufficiently considered all sides of the
debate decided that it would in fact be
better for the well-being of all
involved if it stopped shooting the
birds from the sky in return the
caretakers and Foundation agents
promised to do their best to clean it
regularly and keep the animals at Bay
but with word of this bizarre tourist
attraction steadily Gathering momentum
as the age of email began to take off
the foundation decided that it would be
best to relocate scp-011 entirely
however agents who had been living in
Woodstock for the prior four years were
hesitant to relocate The Entity to a
test chamber or storage facility the
benefits that it had brought to the
local community far outweighed the risks
and threats that it posed the statue had
become a local celebrity smiling and
waving at children who went past and
even offering brief history lessons to
any confused tourists who found
themselves wandering through the park
most just assumed it was a person in
gray paint it was agent Khan who came up
with the idea of relocating scp-011 to a
museum being kept indoors away from the
dangers of any fecal bombing runs was
the main priority Khan argued that
within a museum the statue would blend
in seamlessly with the exhibits around
it furthermore if anyone did see the
statue move or talk they would assume
that it was an interactive exhibit and
treated as such having shown a real love
for Academia history and debate Khan
believed that scp-011 would benefit
greatly from being in such a setting
both learning and eventually even
teaching about the history of the
American Civil War however when all
these arguments were put forward to the
Statue itself it was hesitant having
spent the entirety of its cognitive
existence standing on the same plinth
shooting at the same pigeons the idea of
relocating to somewhere new and unknown
was very intimidating even with the
Soldier's mindset scp-011 was still
feeling incredibly nervous of out the
idea of moving house agent Khan and
scp-011 found themselves locked in a
stalemate try as she might convincing
the SCP to leave its current home was
like talking to a brick wall or rather a
Stonewall the pair of them ended up
dropping the conversation for a couple
years focused instead on psychiatric
evaluations and history lessons for the
SCP in 2002 the foundation officially
declared that scp-011 had achieved
sentience with a great enough level of
self-awareness to pass as a normal human
being aside from the fact that it was
composed entirely of stone for two years
agent Khan talked to scp-011 every day
on the Park Bench the slats on the bench
had to be replaced several times as the
weight of the statue broke through them
snapping them clean in half on several
occasions during this period the pair of
them built up a rapport rarely seen
between humans and scps so much so that
in 2004 agent Khan managed to convince
scp-011 to move to a local Museum on one
condition she would go as well the
foundation agreed to the terms deciding
that Khan could take on the role of
being a researcher in the museum that
way she could keep an eye on scp-011 and
Report any activities while the
foundation officially relinquished
control over the SCP what happened next
was perhaps rather predictable or at
least it would be predictable to anyone
who had worked with agent Khan and
scp-011 during that time in Vermont as
the pair of them moved into their new
lives at the Museum romantic feelings
blossomed between
seeing as scp-011 is officially outside
of the SCP foundation's jurisdiction
there has been no official inquiry into
the nature and practicalities of the
relationship between the woman and the
statue but from the reports that make
their way to the foundation every three
months it is clear that both are very
much enjoying the privacy of their new
Arrangement Roger Pascal closed his eyes
Imagining the barrel racing higher and
higher until it was pointed squarely at
his face he had been told by his bosses
not to ask questions about the origins
of the statue that had suddenly appeared
in the Civil War section even when he
saw the statue's eyes moving he'd kept
his mouth shut that was until he was
doing his security rounds that night and
heard those booming footsteps leading
him behind one of the displays he had
rushed over in a panic peering around
the corner he had been shocked to see
Miss Khan one of the researchers here
and the Civil War statue engaged in a
passionate kiss he had turned and bolted
as fast as he could until he ended up
here terrified on the floor as he
imagined the musket being leveled at him
but then a second pair of footsteps
joined the group and a woman's laugh
filled the room opening his eyes the
security guard saw the pair of them the
statue and the researcher standing in
the doorway laughing about the whole
situation the musket was slung over the
man's shoulder as he offered a cold
Stony hand down to the security guard to
help him up ironically there was
something about the statue's smile that
softened Roger's Stony heart as he was
hauled to his feet I have so many
questions now check out SCP-173 origin
story how 173 got to site 19 and
scp-1913 deadly Monster Squad the furies